[Music]
thank you
don't count your chickens before they're
hatched
many hands make light work
a bad Penny always turns up
[Music]
actions speak louder than words
[Music]
you are never too old to learn
[Music]
cheer is worth a thousand words
absence makes the heart grow fonder
[Music]
grasp no more than thy hand will hold
never judged by appearances
birds of a feather flock together
foreign
loaf is better than no bread
if a job is worth doing it is worth
doing well
[Music]
there is none so blind as those who will
not see
the early bird catches the worm
honesty is the best policy
foreign
Must Fall
beauty is only skin deep
don't cross a bridge until you come to
it
and bygones be bygones
a stumble May prevent a fall
speak the truth and shame the devil
slow but sure
don't put all your eggs in one basket
All That Glitters Is Not Gold
the grass is always greener on the other
side
foreign
to everything there is a season
as you sow so shall you reap
two wrongs don't make a right
better late than never
[Music]
you cannot make an omelet without
breaking a few eggs
practice makes perfect
there is no time like the present
hope for the best prepare for the worst
you can lead a horse to water but you
can't make him drink
there's no place like home
[Music]
don't put off until tomorrow what you
can do today
a bicycle can't stand on its own because
it's too tired
[Music]
if you want to judge a man's character
give him power
[Music]
if wishes were horses Beggars would ride
[Music]
a stitch in time saves nine
yeah
sticks and stones will break my bones
but names will never hurt me
[Music]
life is what you make of it
a man is as old as he feels himself to
be
[Music]
everyone must row with the oars he has
least said soonest mended
thank you
a trouble shared is a troubled hand
where there's a will there's a way
[Music]
you never know what you can do until you
try
[Music]
one father is more than a hundred School
Masters
success has many fathers failure is an
orphan
[Music]
one of these days is none of these days
[Music]
elbow grease is the best polish
proportion your expenses to what you
have not what you expect
don't try to run before you can walk
[Music]
worry often gives a small thing a big
shadow
foreign
[Music]
all happiness is in the mind
nothing ventured nothing gained
[Music]
it's never too late to mend
[Music]
patience wears away stones
[Music]
cheaters never win and winners never
cheat
a good example is the best sermon
some men go through a forest and see no
firewood
[Music]
do not be in a hurry to tie what you
cannot untie
[Music]
slow and steady wins the race
[Music]
lose an hour in the morning and you'll
be running after it all day
foreign
is the proper fruit of knowledge
[Music]
all good things come to those who wait
a smooth sea never made a skilled
Mariner
a word to the wise is enough
after a storm comes the calm
all's for the best and the best of all
possible worlds
don't look a gift horse in the mouth
[Music]
all's well that ends well
[Music]
eye for an eye and a tooth for a tooth
any port in a storm
[Music]
ashes to ashes dust to dust
ask a silly question and you'll get a
silly answer
don't let the cat out of the bag
[Music]
a chain is only as strong as its weakest
link
the best things in life are free
don't bite the hand that feeds you
better to light a candle than to curse
the darkness
don't cast your pearls before the swine
all's fair in Love and War
the Apple never Falls far from the tree
foreign
between two stools one falls to the
ground
blood is thicker than water
[Music]
a slice of bread always falls buttered
side down
business before pleasure
children and fools tell the truth
don't meet troubles halfway
a barking dog never bites
cleanliness is Next to Godliness
a rolling stone gathers no Moss
[Music]
the cobbler always wears the worst shoes
an English man's home is his castle
[Music]
brevity is the soul of wit
cowards may die many times before their
deaths
The Darkest Hour is just before the dawn
[Music]
a fool in his money are soon parted
don't leave your manners on the doorstep
doubt is the beginning not the end of
wisdom
empty vessels make the most noise
enough is as good as a feast
a good beginning makes a good ending
don't put the cart before the horse
[Music]
every stick has two ends
[Music]
fish and guests smell after three days
[Music]
Fools Rush In Where Angels Fear To Tread
forewarned is forearmed
foreign
give the devil his due
good fences make good neighbors
good things come in small packages
and Rocks the Cradle rules the world
[Music]
hard work never hurt anyone
[Music]
who laughs last laughs best
the man who is his own lawyer has a fool
for a client
[Music]
he who lives by the sword shall die by
the sword
honey catches more flies than vinegar
you can't beat him join him
if you lie down with dogs you will get
up with fleas
[Music]
a poor Workman always blames his tools
in the land of the blind the one-eyed
man is King
it's no use crying over spilled milk
[Music]
judge not lest ye be judged
keep your friends close and your enemies
closer
let sleeping dogs lie
Mighty Oaks from Little acorns grow
[Music]
never judge a book by its cover
you can't make bricks without straw
don't burn the candle at both ends
you are what you eat
two heads are better than one
where there's muck there's brass
don't cut off your nose in spite of your
face
[Music]
a watched pot never boils
if it ain't broke don't fix it
thank you
if you play with fire you'll get burned
[Music]
where there's smoke there's fire
a poison tree Bears poison fruit
a fool at 40 is a fool forever
[Music]
all cats love fish but hate to get their
paws wet
[Music]
a loaded wagon makes no noise
[Music]
one rotten apple spoils the whole Barrel
don't make a mountain out of a molehill
[Music]
a tree is known by its fruit
[Music]
don't spit into the wind
[Music]
a young idler an old beggar
[Music]
better an egg today than a hen tomorrow
Bloom where you are planted
[Music]
a fish always rots from the head down
born with a silver spoon in your mouth
[Music]
by hook or by crook
desperate times call for desperate
measures
don't bite off more than you could chew
[Music]
the ends justify the means
fool me once shame on you fool me twice
shame on me
[Music]
good and quickly seldom meet
[Music]
A friend in need is a friend indeed
foreign
makes waste
a new broom sweeps cleaned
however long the night the dawn will
break
it takes both rain and sunshine to make
rainbows
a penny saved is a penny earned
[Music]
a nod is as good as a wink to a blind
horse
[Music]
don't kill the goose that lays the
golden egg
a silent woman is a gift from God
[Music]
The Longest Mile is the last one home
misfortunes never come seeingly
monkey see monkey do
no woman gets an orgasm from shining the
kitchen floor
[Music]